[Música]
después de darse a conocer que Rusia
desplegó drones de fabricación iraní en
sus ataques en territorio ucraniano la
guerra en ese país del este de Europa ha
dado una especie de giro que preocupa
mucho a occidente por el surgimiento de
la alianza ruso iraní esta relación
entre estos dos países es histórica y ha
estado plagada de altibajos e intereses
por eso queda ahora la pregunta sobre la
mesa que puede tener de diferente en
esta oportunidad cuando hay cierta
rivalidad entre estos dos países y hay
una relación que mirándolo a simple
vista pues no se complementa lo cierto
Es que otros actores de la región miran
con muchas suspicacia los movimientos
que está dando la República islámica por
ejemplo Turquía en particular ve
Atentamente como Irán está involucrado
en Siria también como está involucrado
en el conflicto entre Armenia hastaz y
azerbaiyán y ahora pues en el conflicto
en Ucrania pero también otro país como
Israel que es el enemigo histórico de
Irán le preocupa mucho que la República
islámica haya dado un salto en el
desarrollo de armamento Como por ejemplo
los drones que le ha entregado a Rusia
los intereses geopolíticos de Irán
trascienden el descontento que hay al
interior del país ya lo hemos dicho acá
lo hemos analizado y lo hemos visto a lo
largo de las últimas semanas a los
iraníes protestando en las calles contra
el gobierno contra la represión estatal
reivindicando los derechos de las
mujeres y también protestando por la
muerte bajo custodia policial de la
joven masa Amin que busca irán con sus
movimientos y con sus alianzas
estratégicas porque él está preocupando
tanto accidente los movimientos y las
decisiones que están tomando enteran
pues lo vamos a analizar en esta edición
del debate de France 24 para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado al doctor
Carlos Alberto Patiño él es profesor de
la Universidad Nacional de Colombia Es
doctor en filosofía e historia es
también experto en conflictos
internacionales contemporáneos y en
durante el siglo 21 es también autor de
diferentes libros también está con
nosotros el doctor Ignacio
rulansky él es becario post doctoral del
conicet en la Universidad Nacional de
San Martín y también es profesor y
coordinador del departamento de medio
oriente de la Universidad Nacional de la
plata en Argentina ustedes nuestros
televidentes también les recuerdo que
son parte del debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas pueden
dejarlas a través de las redes sociales
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta para que deje
los comentarios es numeral el debate f24
también les recuerdo que todos los
contenidos de este programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
Pues muy bien entonces comienzo dándole
la bienvenida al doctor Carlos Alberto
en la ciudad de Bogotá Gracias por estar
con nosotros Carlos Gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa Punto de
partida para conocer opiniones de los
invitados
qué análisis hace usted de estos
movimientos que está dando Irán en
movimientos estratégicos involucrándose
un poco más en unos conflictos tomando
partido en otros cuál puede ser la
agenda de Teherán
una serie de asuntos bastante amplios
desde la perspectiva del estado iraní en
el con respecto a qué es lo que busca
pero evidentemente habría que decir que
hay una un elemento básico inicial Y es
que Rusia e Irán comparten enemigos y
comparten enemigos en este caso es en
los Estados Unidos y el mundo occidental
hay que recordar que además en medio de
toda esta guerra continúa la presión y
la negociación o en el programa nuclear
iraní y en las últimas semanas el
presidente yo va a llenar ratificado que
Apuesta por la vía diplomática a pesar
de la presión de Israel para generar un
castigo militar e incluso una posible
destrucción anticipada del programa
nuclear iraní en este contexto más las
digamos advertencias y en las últimas 24
horas hemos tenido nueva advertencia del
presidente Vladimir Putin de que una
posible comparación de cáncer mundial
estaría todavía al alcance lo que
pudiera suceder en este contexto pues no
sería digamos algo realmente sorpresivo
Qué papeles están jugando aquí hay que
decir que de alguna manera Irán y Rusia
arman un frente geopolítico mientras que
Turquía e Israel que no son la funda de
los países occidentales y ellos también
lo claro tienen otra agenda y otra
posición geopolítica distinta que
también lo vamos a analizar en este
programa le doy ahora la palabra al
doctor Ignacio rulanski Bienvenido al
programa doctor rolansky Gracias por
estar con nosotros y la pregunta inicial
la misma pregunta que le hacía a Carlos
que puede estar buscando irán con estos
movimientos que está dando como han
calificado en algunos países de
occidente lentos pero seguros y certeros
Qué tal Buenas tardes gracias por la
invitación Bueno en línea con lo que
comentaba Carlos recién entiendo que
parte de esta asistencia que Está
realizando irán con respecto a la
intervención militar o rusa en Ucrania
puede tener que ver con una especie de
quick es decir
un tipo de participación donde
los envíos de aviones no tripulados de
drones de fabricación iraní
encuentren una contrapartida por parte
de Rusia
en cierta asistencia en el desarrollo de
los programas nucleares en los que
estábamos este bueno los que estaban
comentando recién en ese sentido lo más
claro lo que más podemos anticipar o por
lo menos para pasar el limpio aquí sin
irnos mucho por las ramas es eso es
decir
hablamos de dos estados par y en este
momento dos estados en sumamente
aislados Irán
enfrentando una serie de protestas
masivas con un carácter inédito es
estabilizando la posibilidad de Irán de
poder
en causar otras actividades normalmente
Entonces
yo iría por ese lado es decir entendería
que lo que buscan en Rusia es ese tipo
de apoyo Bueno quiero profundizar en
este tema que es el primero que tengo
para la agenda del programa y es esa
relación entre Rusia y Teherán es una
relación que históricamente ha tenido
muchos altibajos lo decía yo en la
introducción de el programa pero dado el
escenario actual puede que estos dos
países tengan la necesidad de
complementarse el uno al otro En qué
estará estructurada más allá de
simplemente tener enemigos en común y
una necesidad de mostrarle músculo o
militar a occidente que está
estructurando Ignacio es Alianza entre
Moscú y Teherán y cuál es el interés que
tiene Moscú en Irán y que tiene Irán en
Moscú
bien bueno es una relación
por un lado comercial desde hace años
que ambos países son socios esto No
necesariamente tiene que ver con la
enemistad que ambos tengan con respecto
a Estados Unidos Irán es un estado que
tiene relaciones comerciales fluidas con
china también pero que lo ha tenido
sobre todo en los años donde se había
consagrado el acuerdo marco entre el
g5+1 irán con Reino Unido Francia
Alemania países de la Unión Europea en
general entonces bueno parte de la de la
relación entre Irán y Rusia está basada
en intereses comerciales que no son para
nada típicos partes intercambios sí
tiene que ver con insumos vinculados a
la investigación y el enriquecimiento de
uranio por eso solamente una parte muy
específica otro tanto tiene que ver con
el mercado eléctrico es decir
nos referimos concretamente a la energía
Irán por supuesto son un gran exportador
de petróleo es uno de los insumos
elementales que exporta por ejemplo a
China también entonces
independientemente de cómo se
estructuran las alianzas y enemistades a
nivel geopolítico lo que cada uno
encuentra en principio es eso
socios comerciales inclusive a veces los
volúmenes de intercambio no son tan
significativos
pero eso es clave por ejemplo en los
vínculos que tiene irán con respecto a
países de América Latina este inclusive
Venezuela no pero pero bueno básicamente
Eso después claro que también hay formas
en que Rusia proyecta sus intereses
geopolíticos al Asia central donde
requiere tener buenas relaciones con
Irán así como también con los demás
países de la región y por otro lado con
respecto al Medio Oriente hacia central
que es una región que le importa mucho a
Rusia y en donde ha perdido terreno
frente a la posición de China allí en
esta región de ese continente pasó a
darle la palabra a Carlos en la ciudad
de Bogotá y le preguntó ahora por este
intercambio los primeros informes dicen
que cerca de 2000 drones
construidos en Irán han sido entregados
o por lo menos ordenados por las fuerzas
militares rusas a cambio para pagar este
pedido Rusia colaborará en asistencia
para el programa nuclear iraní Esta es
la preocupación de occidente ese
programa nuclear iraní eso es lo que
tema Estados Unidos y tema Europa
Bueno la verdad es que estamos en un
momento crucial no solo frente al
programa lo que venís sino también
frente a las armas nucleares rusas y
estamos en el momento de preocupación y
de rearme además que implicado una
especie de aumento acelerado de los
presupuestos de seguridad y defensa como
no habíamos visto desde el final de la
guerra fría y en ese contexto Pues hay
una preocupación realmente muy seria de
Hacia dónde iba a irán con su programa
nuclear Esto es lo que hace entendible
la preocupación israelí por el programa
nuclear
iraní y obviamente hay que recordar aquí
pues momentos tan tensos como las
amenazas de mazmodás marinas ya sobre
Israel por ejemplo o todo el asunto que
está alrededor de cómo cómo quién podría
garantizar esta condición de la
proliferación de armamentos nucleares
porque esta cooperación de Rusia con
Irán también tiene una contraparte
importante de la cooperación de Rusia en
el programa nuclear indio un programa
que se inició en 1962 y que el mercado
en la disputa con Pakistán en este
contexto hay que recordar que Irán
además tiene una cierta autonomía en la
capacidad de producción de armamento
propio el caso de estos drones ha sido
quizás uno de los elementos de mayor
sorpresa táctica en el marco de la
guerra y que han ocasionado parte de los
daños más importantes que ha sufrido
quieto en las últimas dos semanas sobre
todo en la infraestructura eléctrica en
este contexto pues la cooperación
preocupa muchísimo y preocupa muchísimo
obviamente Cuáles son los mecanismos de
seguridad que puede haber frente a una
explosión a un momento de apertura de
competencia muy fuerte de armamentos a
nivel global Carlos además que continuó
con usted además que aquí hay un guión
que ya está poniendo en práctica Rusia
en el conflicto en Ucrania que atenderán
tal vez la resulta Muy atractivo y es
esta carta de chantaje digámoslo así a
occidente que es el uso de las armas
nucleares es la forma como Ucrania pues
se ha visto Perdón Rusia se ha visto
cuando necesitado volver a ejercer una
posición fuerte en el conflicto frente a
la Unión Europea o a Estados Unidos o la
misma Ucrania saca la posibilidad de
usar las armas nucleares que sabemos que
es una de las grandes potencias a nivel
internacional este puede ser un
escenario en el que Irán quiere llegar a
estar para poder hacer esta misma
estrategia con Israel hasta con la misma
Turquía incluso con el resto de Europa y
con Estados Unidos
hay que recordar un hecho básico de las
armas nucleares Y es que las armas
nucleares se otorgan lo que las
estrategias han llamado la
invulnerabilidad estratégica es decir
que se supone que un estado que tiene
armas nucleares pues no se verá atacado
por lo menos de una guerra simétrica por
parte de otro estado y eso Obviamente le
da una ventaja importante frente a la
guerra Aunque en el contexto actual de
la guerra en Ucrania estamos viendo algo
paradójico y es que una potencia nuclear
como Rusia está siendo confrontada
fuertemente por una guerra convencional
por un estado menos poderoso que sería
Ucrania en este contexto aparece
adicionalmente otro asunto que es muy
importante y es una especie de
competencia cultural y religiosa que
tiene Turquía con Irán por una especie
de Liderazgo global del mundo musulmán
aunque las tradiciones unitas y chinitas
sean completamente diferentes ahí hay
digamos un asunto muy importante de
prestigio y reconocimiento Global en ese
contexto pues obviamente empezamos a
enfrentarnos a unos desafíos
estratégicos para los que parecieran no
existir
una especie de mecanismo ni diplomático
ni militar de Osorio importante ese
punto de esa relación con Turquía lo
tengo también para analizar en unos
minutos vamos a llegar a este tema
terminó por preguntarle a Ignacio en
Argentina sobre esta venta de los drones
para finalizar este tema Si varias de
las especulaciones que he visto y he
leído a lo largo de esta semana sobre
este tema Es que esto involucraría
directamente a Irán en el conflicto pero
es que Turquía también le ha vendido
drones a Ucrania entonces pero Ucrania
no se ha visto involucrado directamente
en el conflicto lo hemos visto como un
país mediadora facilitado la salida de
los barcos con cereales ha ofrecido el
territorio Turco para mesas de diálogos
aquí se está simplemente satanizando el
personaje de Irán como un actor
internacional por ser Irán y se le está
involucrando en el conflicto porque así
lo quiere ver occidente
Bueno lo que marcas es una de las
grandes ironías o hipocresías de del
mercado de venta de armas indudablemente
de hecho la digamos la exportación de
armas por parte de Turquía Ucrania se da
a raíz de un triángulo
de venta de suministros bastante
particular que también conjuga en Rusia
y que aleja en un momento a Turquía de
Estados Unidos que buscaba justamente
acceder a tecnología militar de Aviación
que solamente podía conseguir Estados
Unidos no vas a conseguir entonces de
Rusia y es cuando empieza a vender a su
vez drones Es decir aviones no
tripulados a Ucrania Es que hoy se están
usando contra Rusia
en cuanto a lo que mencionás sobre Irán
bueno es cierto pero también como
planteas no es decir por un lado Turquía
actú como una especie de mediador de
patrocinador de un cierto proceso de paz
y por más que eso no esté llegando a
buen Puerto sí Por lo pronto Al haber
destrabado aunque sea parcialmente las
exportaciones de cereales eso ha sido
saludado por la comunidad internacional
inclusive y especialmente por países del
Golfo
me refiero por supuesto a las otras
orillas del Golfo Pérsico
Qatar macri inhibidatos árabes Unidos
etcétera que dependen fuertemente de
esas importaciones también otros países
del Mediterráneo Oriental y el norte de
África bueno para ser concreto Entonces
Irán no no participa
No tendríamos de ninguna iniciativa esas
características porque no es La retórica
no es el papel que Irán viene esbozando
ensayando y no es el papel que le ha
permitido jugar tampoco la comunidad
internacional en todo caso estos drones
digamos la participación militar iraní
de forma indirecta en el conflicto en la
guerra ruso ucraniana tiene por
condición según está trascendiendo en
los últimos días
el alcance de objetivos que incluyan
sitios de peregrinación para las
comunidades judías para
turistas y israelíes Es decir de alguna
manera exporta
un conflicto regional a otro más
específico en este caso entre Ucrania y
Rusia en territorio ucraniano Entonces
el uso de los drones iraníes tiene toda
otra significado también no es que
digamos es satanizado solo digamos por
una sola cuestión pero es cierto que es
una participación que tiene otras
características y la política exterior
iraní también tiene otras
características en general le traslado
la pregunta a Carlos en Colombia Usted
lo ve como parte de este discurso de
occidente simplemente satanizar a Irán y
quererlo involucrar en este conflicto
por venderle estos drones a Rusia cuando
vemos Que Turquía Pues también le vende
estos drones complementando un poco lo
que ha dicho Ignacio
No creo que el asunto es más complicado
que simplemente satanizar a Irán Irán No
no ha sido necesariamente una especie de
potencia cooperadora es más habría que
recordar por ejemplo Que que el gran
vaya toda de que sea la revolución
irraín rojo
renunció explícitamente al programa
nuclear que además entre otras y era una
había iniciado de la mano los Estados
Unidos en la década en 1970 pero fueron
los continuadores de la Revolución una
vez muerto quienes de alguna manera
rescatan el programa nuclear a mí en
este contexto y quiero insistir Irán no
está utilizando el problema nuclear
únicamente como una especie y no es
solamente una especie de satanización
del mundo occidental sino que utiliza el
programa nuclear como una condición
clave de posicionamiento entre los
países musulmanes y obviamente
conociendo el único país de mayoría
chiquita con una Revolución en medio de
chiquita Hasta ahora exitosa faltará ver
en qué va a terminar todo este conjunto
de rebeliones sociales y populares pero
lo cierto es que el asunto es mucho más
complicado que una satanización
iraní no ha sido necesariamente ni
colaborador ni transparente ahora eso
tampoco avala obviamente la ruptura de
los acuerdos que se han logrado el
problema nuclear por lo menos desde mi
perspectiva por parte del ex presidente
Donald Trump frente a frente a Irán era
mejor haber tenido una palanca
diplomática que carecer de ella en este
contexto bélico claramente la diplomacia
haciendo ahí gala de sus herramientas en
este tipo de conflictos Carlos Entonces
en este escenario que usted nos explica
ver a Irán recibiendo ayuda rusa para
desarrollar su programa nuclear entrando
en el mercado internacional de drones
que había desplegado o había utilizado
en cierta forma para algunos intereses
muy puntuales en países como yemen o en
Irak ahora lo vemos en un escenario
internacional esto es un paso más hacia
arriba escalado y también le permite ver
cómo funcionan estos productos digamos
en en terreno en un combate de verdad
abierto esto cambia también la posición
de de Irán a nivel internacional ahora
como un actor que tiene desarrollado una
industria militar en donde también
compite con Turquía que ha desarrollado
rápidamente una industria armamentística
Sí la verdad es que estamos frente a un
mecanismo de confrontación muy
interesante de entornos industriales
militares y de competencia y está
digamos una de las contracaras que a
veces la opinión pública no logra captar
que está detrás de la guerra y ese
estamos frente a una especie de
competencia muy fuerte habría que
recordar las palabras del presidente
Putin en la última semana y la necesidad
de renovar el complejo Industrial
militar ruso producir más armamento Pero
además nuevo armamento con nueva
tecnología mi parte de lo que está en el
centro de esta guerra es quien accede A
qué tipo de tecnología y quién
desarrolla Qué tipos de tecnología líder
y este como lo es Ignacio hace un
momento aquí por ejemplo Hay un problema
es quien acceda tecnología de la
navegación para naves de combate o qué
va a pasar por ejemplo en la evaluación
que los estrategas comienzan a hacer en
la primacía entre drones versus tanques
de guerra todo este asunto implica un
cambio radical de modelo tecnológico
frente a la guerra y obviamente estamos
frente a una competencia estratégica
realmente muy seria que de alguna manera
podría suponer una un cambio bastante
radical sobre la concepción y las formas
de hacer la guerra en el mundo
contemporáneo Ignacio tenemos que
meternos a hablar de el tema de Turquía
que es tal vez uno de los países que
está viendo con más preocupación la
alianza entre Teherán y Moscú y que está
viendo cómo cómo Se involucra en otros
en otros conflictos cercanos por ejemplo
la posición que tiene Irán frente al
conflicto entre Armenia y azerbaiyán
recordemos que Irán está apoyando a el
gobierno armenio en este conflicto en la
región de nagorno caravag y que a su vez
Turquía está apoyando militarmente y
estratégicamente al gobierno azerbaiyán
aquí el temor de Turquía va más allá de
simplemente perder un poco de terreno en
la influencia en la región va más allá
en términos militares y en términos
políticos o usted qué piensa
se me cortó un pedacito de la pregunta
Disculpa Se me fue la señal sí Le repito
quiero tocar el tema de Turquía sobre la
preocupación que tiene por esta Alianza
con Moscú y los movimientos que hace en
el cáucaso en el sur del cáucaso y en
otros en otros movimientos que ha hecho
Irán en la región allí en medio oriente
es decir la respuesta de Turquía con
respecto al cáucaso sí sí sí sí sí
la preocupación turca en general
Ok bien bueno
Me parece que tiene que ver también con
parte del rol que busca ensayar Turquía
en general
tanto para el este Europa Como por
ejemplo para el medio oriente y el cabo
casos de decirle ser un actor
pacificador un actor mediador un poco
este papel que vimos que intentó ensayar
con
Ucrania y Rusia y por supuesto toda
fuerza desestabilizadora en el cáucaso
es un motivo de preocupación
Turquía tiene la llave de los estrechos
del fósforo y de los dardanelos al mar
Negro por tanto es un país que tiene
cierto músculo si es una potencia
militar clave para esa región
pero a su vez no es un país que quiera
verse involucrado arrastrado en un
conflicto entonces
en ciertas amenazas que vienen de Irán
sobre todo en los últimos meses
Estableciendo que Irán respondería de
sentirse amenazado
también vis a vis el acercamiento que se
da entre Turquía e Israel sobre todo a
partir de este último año hace que para
Turquía sea necesario por ejemplo este
encuentro de ministros de relaciones
exteriores con
su contraparte israelí para tratar de
establecer una agenda de cooperación en
materia de seguridad
particularmente para para el cáucaso
entonces
Solo que lo que estoy viendo es
esfuerzos En todo caso por aceptar esa
vía
de cooperación multilateral con Israel
Es decir de generar una especie de
frente común que permita coordinar
esfuerzos y que esto sea un factor
disuasivo para Irán tanto como para
Rusia es decir
Mostrar que que no es tan fácil
proyectar intereses ni para Irán y para
Rusia del cauca
y que piensa Carlos en la ciudad de
Bogotá un temor infundado allí en ankara
por parte de los turcos a este Avance
iraní en la región o cómo lo ve usted
no yo creo que en este caso Ignacio
tiene toda la razón ahí hay un problema
muy serio sobre cómo se reparten las
cargas y los pesos y contrapesos en el
cáucaso y obviamente hay que recordar
que en este caso la guerra a la guerra
Armenia azerbaiyán siempre un conflicto
no resuelto inició en 1989 Y de forma
intermitente hasta continuo hasta el día
de hoy pues hace que este acercamiento
Irán Rusia sea realmente de alta
preocupación para el caso de Turquía y
en ese contexto habría que recorrer por
ejemplo las intervenciones militares de
Turquía en el norte de Siria durante
todos estos años de guerra en Siria o el
intento de controlar a los kurdos y
obviamente todo este asunto tiene que
ver con los intereses iraní es donde
chocan dónde están Dónde se encuentran y
obviamente me implica establecer una
agenda de cooperación muy seria muy
importante entre Turquía e Israel en
este caso habría que recordar además que
la perspectiva de Israel no es solamente
Buscar una cooperación de alguna manera
para
contrarrestar la fuerza de Irán con
Turquía sino que también habrá que
recordar los llamados pactos de Abraham
que han implicado que han permitido que
Israel abra con las monarquías árabes
otros mecanismos de cooperación en la
misma sentido en la dirección de
establecer una especie de control o de
moderación de la agenda política iraní
en Carlos justamente el ministro de
defensa de Israel benigans se está
reuniendo con homólogo Turco un Lucy
akar y hay varios temas todo esto para
poder impulsar nuevamente las relaciones
entre los dos países que estaban rotas
por diferentes motivos desde hace
algunos años pero uno de los puntos
claves es justamente Irán Pero hay dos
frentes que entonces ve uno que se
pueden colaborar allí los dos países es
la guerra en Ucrania y también que
Turquía le siga sirviendo de Puente a
Israel para acercarse a las monarquías
de la Península arábiga aquí entonces se
vería Israel arrastrado a ese conflicto
en Ucrania que es uno de los grandes
reclamos que ha hecho el presidente
celenski siempre pidió a lo largo de
estos meses la ayuda de Israel Israel
dijo yo le puedo ayudar en materia
táctica y tal vez a crear un escudo
antimisiles pero yo no le voy a
suministrar armas sino me voy a meter
ahora el escenario es muy complejo es
muy distinto para Israel
dos aclaraciones no no creo que Turquía
tenga mucho que hacer en abrir la puerta
de las monarquías monarquías árabes a
Israel creo que en ese caso la vías por
otras condiciones distintas hay que
habría que recordar que hay una
competencia por prestigio y
reconocimiento musulmán entre por lo
menos Arabia Saudita el mismo Egipto y
Turquía parte de los mundos culturales
dentro del islam completamente distintos
pero más allá de este asunto quiero
recordar y ya lo decía ahora
mencionaba Ignacio ligeramente es que
una de las características más
interesantes de la Ucrania contemporánea
es que hay una serie de comunidades
judías muy importantes en Ucrania
Empezando por la comunidad judía en la
ciudad de Odessa y habría que recordar
todo el papel del rabino a lo largo de
la guerra del del Gran rabino de Odessa
planteando una serie de exposiciones y
reflexiones políticas y culturales muy
serias sobre la permanencia de estas
comunidades universidades en este
territorio de forma tal que es y la
sombra de Irán amenaza a las comunidades
judías esto de alguna manera pues
implica una posición reposicionamiento
del Estado Israel y muy seguramente este
acercamiento y Irán Rusia implicará
desde mi perspectiva un cambio de
posición y de reconsideración de Israel
frente a la guerra en Ucrania y pasa a
preguntarle ahora Ignacio por otro actor
importante en este escenario de medio
oriente y es la situación en Siria esto
redistribuye cargas porque hay intereses
encontrados allí entre Rusia Irán
Turquía Estados Unidos Israel es una
gran mezcla en donde todos chocan y
confluyen esto podría reactivar el
conflicto ponerle un punto final
redistribuir las cargas que se puede
analizar de de del conflicto sirio de
estos avances iraníes
bueno parece clave a ver el Carlos acá
había explicado muy claramente como de
hecho ya el frente sirio constituía un
problema para Turquía no relacionando
esto con la pregunta anterior y hago una
salvedad respecto a la posición
israelí sobre el eventual apoyo de ser
la posible venta de armas a ucranianas
que que preguntabas antes ahí hay que
tener cuidado porque Ven y gantts lo
único que por el momento
comunicó a selens que yo hizo público es
que estaría dispuesto tal vez y esto los
medios israelíes lo están criticando
bastante entre comillas no que tal vez
facilitaría tecnología que Ucrania ya se
desarrolló por su propia cuenta no es
decir es una especie de sistema
antimisiles limitado No necesariamente
el aerondom que es lo que está pidiendo
Ucrania Pero bueno
digamos esto transitando cierta este
cierto repudio este inclusive dentro de
Israel donde no No necesariamente
entienden Por qué su gobierno no apoya
más enfáticamente Ucrania en cuanto a
Siria ha sido el escenario clave de
configuración de la presencia rusa en el
medio oriente
efectivamente una especie de válvula
para regular la presencia de his bola de
Irán en Siria y también
una válvula para la intervención militar
y logística israelí que buscaba
neutralizar la presencia tanto de fisgo
la comodidad en este país en los últimos
años el apoyo militar ruso al gobierno
de bazar a Lázaro le permitió al
presidente sirio reconquistar buena
parte de los territorios que estaban en
manos de grupos Rebeldes y Delicias o el
estado islámico en este momento ese
proceso está bastante completo no del
todo por supuesto
el intento de legitimación a partir de
unas elecciones sumamente arbitrarias y
poco transparentes no es suficiente para
decir que se le puede poner punto final
a la guerra civil en Siria y este
momento particular donde Rusia tiene
mucho menos margen para seguir actuando
en Siria donde eran una especie de
laboratorio de campo de entrenamiento de
sus propias fuerzas de capacitación de
los militares que están ahora
combatiendo en Ucrania y perdiendo por
el momento la guerra Bueno este momento
ya Rusia no tiene la capacidad de estar
tan presente y por tanto el peligro en
todo caso es que
las tensiones se reanuden o que en
determinado momento veamos bolsones de
territorios donde hayan enfrentamientos
inclusive posibles ataques en cuanto al
tema refugiados que es lo que más está
hablando ahora
una especie de retornos forzoso de
refugiados desde
a Siria por ejemplo podría poner en una
situación sumamente vulnerable a
población que ya viene atravesando una
situación sumamente precaria desde hace
años entonces se abren nuevas
posibilidades de
vulnerabilidades para para los grupos
que viven en Siria y bueno y a su vez
cierro con esto pero Irán también tiene
mucho menos capacidad de de tener
digamos de mantener su presencia en
Siria no es decir en Siria podría
volverse una tierra de nadie en mucho
más contundentemente de lo que ya venía
haciendo claro para esta última parte el
programa quiero que analicemos el tema
al interior de Irán hemos reportado aquí
en France 24 a lo largo de las últimas
semanas las manifestaciones ciudadanas
que ha habido a raíz de la muerte de una
joven que estaba en custodia policial
esto ha desencadenado también un
descontento que ya venía también
Arrastrando la sociedad de iraní desde
hace varios meses por
económica que está viviendo el país y se
han visto unas manifestaciones y también
represión fuertemente por parte de los
cuerpos de seguridad allí en Irán qué
podemos decir al interior de la
situación que se vive en Irán Carlos son
grietas que se empiezan a armar allí de
esta Revolución que siempre ha utilizado
el miedo y la represión para poderse
mantener firme entre sus ciudadanos este
estas manifestaciones se pueden tomar
como un antes y un después de esa
revolución
posiblemente puede ser una decisión
después de estar después de rebeliones
dentro de la revoluciones y sin embargo
hay que recordar que lo que viene
sucediendo está en el marco de una serie
de explosiones periódicas que hemos
registrado en Irán a lo largo de los
últimos 20 años y que han sido todas
reprimidas con la mayor severidad y la
mayor capacidad de coerción posible que
tenga el régimen sin embargo y lo más
inaudito y lo más interesante en este
caso no es que hemos visto que durante
semanas han salido a protestar no sólo
miles de mujeres que se han quitado el
velo que lo han quemado que lo han
tirado al aire etcétera sino que además
acompañadas por miles de centenares de
miles de hombres que también salen
apoyarlas y empieza a producirse una
especie de petición de libertades
individuales y apertura ahora a dónde
vaya a llegar a uno es incierto No no
creo que esto haya haya llegado haya
tenido una especie de momento de de
punto culminante frente a la Revolución
y los cambios políticos que se podrían
esperar de mayor apertura de libertad
individuales aquí hay que recordar
además que estamos es frente a uno de
los fenómenos más paradójicos del mundo
contemporáneo de restricción de la
libertad es individuales especialmente
de la restricciones elementales
individuales de las mujeres y de la
incapacidad para que las mujeres tomen
sus propias decisiones esto podría
convertirse en una especie de acicate
Sin embargo aquí el régimen siempre se
despliega de manera brutal con un apoyo
absolutamente decidido de los cuerpos de
comercio Ignacio qué lectura si usted de
estos movimientos a nivel internacional
queda Irán para poder mitigar justamente
lo que está sucediendo al interior del
país Mostrar éxitos o logros o alcances
a nivel internacional lo mejor
posicionamiento para apaciguar un poco
los ánimos dentro del país
bueno lamentablemente me perdí una parte
de la respuesta de Carlos pero escuché
casi todo y me pareció clarísimo y
sumamente
importante para para explicar esto otro
también porque
Bueno creo que Irán no está haciendo
capaz de transmitir una imagen que
contrarreste las muy elocuentes imágenes
vídeos
hashtags textos demandas que van
surgiendo desde la sociedad civil a
partir de activismos que de vuelta
enfrentan Como dijo recién el compañero
situaciones sumamente adversas para
salir a la casa es decir conquistar el
espacio público lo están haciendo desde
estudiantes de escuela secundarias hasta
adultos grandes atletas cineastas
artistas es decir todo tipo de
profesionales digamos de De punta a
punta al país
las distintas etnias grupos religiosos
están básicamente todos apoyando estas
mismas consignas y realmente no veo que
exista estrategia de ni de software ni
ni imagen pública que logre revertir lo
que para la comunidad internacional es
más que aparente no Además que evidente
pues Ignacio y a Carlos Alberto les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
y haber hecho este análisis de la
situación en irakil en Irán y los
movimientos que ha hecho a nivel
internacional este análisis para la
audiencia de France 24 Muchas gracias
por haber estado con nosotros si ustedes
Muchas gracias por la sintonía les
recuerdo también que la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Laura garzón
y la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera Muchas gracias
por su sintonía
[Música]